Hamburger Festwochen bei klicksum Simon
von MTV Game One war da Budi wird kommen
johannes örding war da und jetzt kommt
Sie Ina Müller seine Freundin und super
in Müller ist super finden wir ganz groß
absolut großartig weil die hat eine
sensationelle Talkshow im
NDR mitten in der Nacht mit riesen
Einschaltquote ist also eine Granate das
werdet ihr sehen und ihr habt jetzt die
Chance ihr eine Frage zu stellen wie es
bei Simon schon gemacht hat habt und was
wollte ich sagen genau se kreativ lest
den Infotext lasst euch was einfallen
und dann
ist eure Frage eigentlich schon fast mit
Garantie dran oder ja auf jeden Fall vor
allen Dingen die Antworten werden super
sein 100pentig auf jeden Fall
sensationell okay also ihr könnt eine
Menge erwarten bis dann Ciao
Banane